si je ne vous ai pas autorisé à lire ce
journal vous feriez mieux d'arrêter de
lire tout de suite je m'appelle jamie
king je suis une artiste
j'écris et je suis une experte de toutes
les belles choses ma meilleure amie
s'appelle isabelle a sans aucun doute la
personne la plus gentille qui existent
pourquoi j'ai l'impression tous les
adultes de ma vie et c'est mon poids
zone et je crois qu'elle ne tournera pas
la tête avant d'en manger un morceau
c'est pour ça que tous les garçons sont
fous de moi six garçons comme atzmon
rivers tu veux tu inscrire pour le
concours de chevaux à la corde
on doit en finir avec cette fille
empoisonné quelqu'un c'est très méchant
l'école est un vrai désastre
comment j'allais survivre sans perdre la
tête sur toi tes points forts
hier
et
à
oui j'ai mis les parfaites semic
allongée de 26 avril un bébé et que
c'était une carte elle ressemblera
exactement ça